-You had a wonderful "SNL"
this past Saturday
with John Mulaney.
-So much fun.
-So nice when John is back
He has just turned into
the consummate "SNL" host.
-It's, like, someone who i
a bigger theater geek than I am.
-And you really put your theater
geekery to week --
to work this week.
-"To week."
-You weeked your geek.
[ Laughter ]
You did "Sound of Music."
-We did, and I do want to say,
I was very proud.
I feel like I did a lot of
the blocking myself
in that scene.
-Oh, really?
-'Cause I was like,
"Liesl runs around
the entire time."
-Gotcha. So did you --
-Behind trees, yeah.
-Did you --
You felt good when it was over
-I was doing a lot of...
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-'Cause you love --
You and John
both love musical theater.
-Yes.
-There was also "Airport Sushi."
-This was a fantastic sketch
about someone who orders
LaGuardia sushi.
-This song in particular
was driving me insane
because it's
a very hard song to do,
"America,"
from "West Side Story."
-Yes.
I think it's a song that, like
people think they can sing
-Right, 'cause you sing along.
-Yeah, like...
♪♪ I'm gonna live in Amer--
But you're saying
it's very hard.
-And then they want you
to do it on live TV.
-Yeah.
-And it's very difficult.
And at one point,
they didn't have the "Bye-bye,
that bit, and I was, like,
we gotta get the "Bye-bye" back.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I --
-It was very important
you got it in there.
Your birthday,
you had an episode.
-Yes.
-Your birthday was on
a Saturday, and you did,
what might be one of my
favorite sketches of the year,
with RuPaul,
that was very
"Designing Women"-inspired
-Yes.
Absolutely.
My favorite scene,
the "Lights Out in Georgia
that Marjorie -- I've called
people Marjorie in my life
when they've driven me crazy
-And this is --
It was never referenced
that this scene
was wholly inspired
by "Designing Women."
-No, but...
-Yes.
I mean,
the look was pretty obvious.
-It was for a specific audience.
[ Laughter ]
And anyone else who enjoyed it
good.
-Did RuPaul understand
the reference point?
-Absolutely.
-Gotcha.
-And it was such a dream
to get to do that with Ru.
I was, like,
"I can't even think about it yet
because I'm gonna happy cry.
-Uh-huh.
-And finally at the end of the
show, I got to, like,
turn to Ru and go, like, "That
was the best moment of my life."
[ Laughter ]
-So, doing "Designing Women"
with RuPaul
is right up
at the top of your list.
-Absolutely.
-You've now been in the show
since 2012.
-I know.
-And you've had a fantastic run.
So many successes.
But I do like more than anything
talking to people
about their bombs.
-Yes.
-Did you have any
hard-core bombs at dress?
-The biggest bomb was --
I don't know if you were there
for it, but Vanessa and I
were playing, like,
two forensic detectives...
-uh-huh.
-...from Buffalo.
-Okay.
-And we just kept going,
"Oh, gross."
[ Laughter ]
And pick it and be, like,
"Ew, there's a --
Oh, it's a -- gross.
Look at that hair."
And it was, like, not a laug
from the second we walked in
and it was like, "Oh, no.
There's four more minuets
of this."
It doesn't change.
-Yeah, there's nothing
more depressing than when
you start a sketch
that has no second move in it.
-Yeah.
-And people wholly are out
on the first move.
-And another character's
gonna enter
and gonna sound the same.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-You have an obsession,
and I remember when I came bac
and hosted, you wrote a sketch
we didn't end up doing it,
about Untuckit shirts.
-Yes, yes.
-Will you sort of speak to
the origins of your obsessio
with these ads?
-Well, it was, like,
right after the 2016 election.
A lot of advertising
was very emotional,
because people
were very emotional,
and talking about their issues
and things
they were scared about.
And then this Untuckit ad
I saw one day,
and it blew my mind
because it's, like,
inspirational music,
kind of, like, contemplative
and he's going,
"There's a lot of problems
in the world,
and we all have them.
And mine was I couldn't find
a shirt that looked good."
[ Laughter ]
And it was, like, "This is s
tone-deaf, it's unreal."
[ Laughter ]
-It made you so angry.
-Yeah.
Well, not even angry.
I actually love it.
-Yeah.
-And I have a friend on Facebook
who, like,
writes me once a month.
-Yeah.
-Untuckit news.
[ Laughter ]
-It's nice --
I guess it's nice that there
are people who are so untroubled
in this era
that they can still be mos
worried about their shirts
-But he wanted to be troubled.
-Yeah.
-He was, like, "I am, too.
I'm getting in on this."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
He would be out with frien
who are genuinely concerne
about and had empathy for,
you know, people who
are having a tough time, and h
was, like, "I'm with you guys.
-"Yeah,
'cause you know what I did?"
-Yeah.
-"I fixed mine.
You guys would be okay, too.
[ Laughter ]
-I laughed very hard
when you did a sketch
with Chance the Rapper this year
where you were on wires.
-Ugh!
-And wire sketches
are very hard,
'cause this is a beautiful still
that makes it look like
it was very easy for you guy
to get up in the air,
but it was not that easy.
-I don't know
that it's that beautiful.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, it's pretty --
-It was always, like,
my little dangly feet
were always kind of funny.
-Yeah.
-No, wire --
Immediately, at air, we went
"Let's go," to go that way
and we were immediately
pulled the wrong way.
[ Laughter ]
So, it's like,
"Oh, it's gonna be great."
[ Laughter ]
And then I was stuck.
They were trying
to hook Beck up.
-Yeah.
-Like, the scene can't end
till Beck's in the air.
-Yeah.
-And I was --
They couldn't hook him up.
So, I was just stuck danglin
upside down over a chair
for like a full minute.
I go,
I've never seen breaks so much
And they're just going,
"Oh, Jennifer.
Oh, Jennifer.
-Yeah, 'cause they couldn'
cut to Beck yet.
-Yeah.
-It makes me laugh so hard
because I love when a characte
in a sketch walks out,
and you can already see wires,
because, you're like,
"Well, clearly this guy
is going up at some point.
Yeah.